all right there's a question from skull
vikings 407 about the vikings do you see
patrick peterson having an end of career
resurgence with minnesota just like
darrell rivas did in new england he may
not have the speed anymore or can you
see him being moved to safety at some
point during the season peterson has
said he's willing to move to safety
going into free agency i was told the
teams that were interested in him were
interested in him purely as a corner now
the vikings have harrison smith we don't
know what's going to happen with anthony
harris he's a free agent his name has
not come up at all this week that i've
noticed but i think patrick peterson
instantly comes in and becomes one of
their best corners simply because they
don't have many they have a need there i
don't know how he's going to hold up but
he's probably going to hold up better
than their other options shireen
yeah you know this is an interesting
signing mike based on what he's done
over the last couple years i mean he's
only 30 years old but gosh it seems like
he's way older than that and a guy that
we're probably going to be discussing
for the hall of fame when you consider
how good his career was over his first
eight seasons in the nfl he was an eight
time pro bowler three-time all-pro he
made the all-decade team i mean he did a
lot he was truly one of the best corners
but he hasn't been that guy
in several years now it's been a long
time 2018 was the last time he went to
the pro bowl so i have seen decline from
him maybe this is a rejuvenation for him
going to minnesota but yes moving to
safety probably seems like something
that would benefit him if not this year
doesn't sound like that's going to
happen this year but after this year
certainly
what do ped violations do to a guy's
hall of fame case i'm not trying to be a
smart ass i mean he had a six-game
suspension for testing positive for a
banned substance and the masking agent
two games on top of it so the masking
agent failed and that it was detected
and it failed to mask the ped
i think it's something you have to
discuss unlike the baseball hall of fame
you know they've they've just taken
these guys and just removed them
completely the nfl will discuss them and
i don't truly know that we've had a guy
who's come up that served a suspension
antonio gates may be the first guy who's
going to come up that we get to talk
about who served us a suspension like
that but it will be interesting to see
how it's handled
in the conversations in that room
because i think he will be in there and
be discussed and you do have to consider
it no question about it
a red zone alk has a question does the
current market for receivers make it
more likely that larry fitzgerald will
retire i'm going to take first track at
this one i say it doesn't matter because
if he plays he's going to be playing to
try to get a ring what he makes won't
matter i could see him going to tampa
bay i could see him going to kansas city
and that comment from november when he
said if the arizona cardinals win the
super bowl he'll retire it was odd at
the time because it's not like they were
a super bowl favorite
but that may have been his clue
that one more year with a super bowl
contender it's not like it's going to
burn any bridges in arizona where i
think he he may have some political
aspirations be a senator at some point i
haven't heard that i just kind of have
that feeling and i think he'd be very
good at it it's a compliment it's not
like he's going to lose his fan base in
arizona if he goes to tampa bay for one
year and happens to win a super bowl
and you know what else he can do mike he
can just buy this time right and wait
and see how everything plays out get
through training camp don't go through
training camp with the team maybe even
get into the season and see how the
season is playing out who looks like the
best team who gives you that best
opportunity to go win a ring and do it
then so it's not going to surprise me if
we don't hear anything about a
retirement announcement from larry
fitzgerald and and we don't hear
anything about him signing with the team
either and this thing thing just plays
out over the next few months
that's a great point you don't have to
sign in july or august or september or
october or november you can wait and
just and
just make sure that you're getting on a
team that truly is a contender for a
super bowl championship before you
decide that that's where you're going to
go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports